billionaires who forbes track have owned
all kinds of horses over the years that
we've pegged values to but when you
think of horse racing today the kentucky
derby the breeders cup the belmont
stakes
all of these races are run by one kind
of horse
thoroughbreds
we're taking a look at one of america's
top thoroughbred breeding farms
spendthrift farm
founded by renowned horse trader and
farm owner leslie combs ii and leader
purchased by the billionaire b-wing
hughes the kentucky farm currently
boasts horses like 20 20 kentucky derby
winner authentic
[Music]
there are many different terms for
thoroughbred horses like foals phillies
mares weanlings and colts but the term
you want to pay the most attention to is
a stallion which is a male horse that's
often a retired racehorse stallions can
be the most valuable assets on a horse
farm and in spenther farms case they
happen to own one horse who is
considered to be pretty much the hottest
stallion in north america right now his
name is into mischief
in august of this year b wayne hughes
died at the age of 87
but there are indications that hughes
transferred ownership of the farm to his
daughter tammy gustafsson and her
husband eric
tammy is a billionaire member of our
forbes 400 rankings just like her dad
was
spent thrift declined to comment on the
ownership transfer
to help us figure out how much these
stallions are worth we talked to several
experts in the equine industry including
two who are called bloodstock agents i
describe myself as a stock broker and a
real estate agent for horses that's chad
schumer he's the founder of schumer
bloodstock agency out of louisville
kentucky our primary focus is buying and
selling thoroughbred racehorses and
breeding stock
along with that
we do insurance on thoroughbreds and we
do appraisals for banks
pretty much if it has to do
with dollars cents and thoroughbreds
we do that and that's peter bradley the
owner of bradley thoroughbreds based in
lexington kentucky stud fees can change
over time depending on how stallions
progeny do once their own racing careers
start in 2012 when into mischief was
seven years old his stead fee was a
reported 7 500
that jumped to 20 000 the next year as
some of his progeny began to win
important races now as a 16 year old
horse into mischief stud fee is up more
than 11 times drawing 225 000
which is the highest advertised stud fee
in north america this year to value a
stallion the general rule of thumb is to
take its stud fee and multiply it by 300
or 400 times that equation assumes the
horse will book that is mate with 100
mares per year over three to four years
but some stallions like into mischief
book many more than that in a year
driving up revenue for the farm and
increasing their own value in turn so
to refine our methodology bloodstock
agent chad schumer suggested that we
factor in the exact ages of each
stallion on the roster and the number of
mares they covered last year in 2020
i advised not take a hundred percent of
the number because obviously all the
mares aren't going to be pregnant some
are going to die some are going to be
barren some will not have live foals so
i think a reasonable estimate is 80 to
of the number of mares bred and the
cover fee and that's the income for one
year now a young horse eight nine ten
eleven years old he could be worth four
or five years worth of income as a horse
gets older i would i would change that
number to two or three but you're buying
an asset and you're like any business
you're looking for a rate of return
and i think the stallions you know
typically you you want to make sure
a good investment in a stallion would
have you out in four or five years based
on this method and using the 2021 stud
fee we determined that into mischief
alone is worth about 135 million dollars
and we estimated the other 2021
stallions combined are worth about 165
million dollars
spendthrift recently announced its 2022
stud fees and bumped into mischief's fee
up once again to 250 000
if we include the estimated values of
the other horses living on spencer farm
like the mayors and yearlings which we
calculate separately we estimate that
all of spencer's horses are worth about
360 million dollars
it all sounds like it's just printing
gold bars but it's not peter bradley
said that roughly 10 to 30
of all stallions that go to stud
actually make it there's a very
polarized market here for the stallions
you know it's either chicken or feathers
the other part we have to value is the
farm itself
first we pulled parcel records from
fayette county where spencer farmed is
located and looked at the fair cash
value of the parcels noting the values
of the land and the buildings on it the
farm is located in kentucky's fayette
county
so we turn to the county assessor's
office in order to pull some public land
records and get a sense for the value
that way the assessor prepares their own
valuations of every parcel in the county
and they take into account the land
itself as well as any buildings that are
on it and i didn't realize this but
apparently the horses actually
graze the actual grass that's on the
land there so although it's not a farm
in the typical sense of it the fact that
it's producing crops the soil
agricultural quality is quite important
because the horses are actually eating
that grass
we looked at just one parcel it was
about 330 acres that parcel itself was
worth 5.9 million dollars so that
included the land plus improvements in
buildings on the land looking at all 15
parcels and adding up those values
brought us to about 25 million
fayette county updates its assessment
every four years most recently on this
farm in 2018 so these numbers may be a
bit low
normally to value land like this we
would look for comparable transactions
but horse farm sales in the area are
rare spent through farm also has another
operation in australia which allows them
to breed more horses during the southern
hemisphere's own distinct breeding
season
we estimate that the land and the horses
who live there are valued at about 15
million
in total we estimate that it's worth 400
million dollars not half bad for the
family farm
[Music]
you